[Music]
in our workshop brent munich and me will
talk about graphql and maui microsoft's
new
framework for building mobile
applications we will start at the basics
by exploring the graphql type system and
the query language with an asp.net core
backend we will look at patterns and
best practices but we won't just accept
them but look at the whys and house as
we have a better understanding about
graphql we will look at maui and explore
how maui can help us building
data-driven reactive applications for
our customers this workshop will dive
deep and is for front-end and back-end
developers as we are taking both
perspectives to really understand the
challenges we are facing in building
modern applications for a cloud-first
mobile first world come and join us it's
going to be a great workshop and i hope
to see you there